how do you overcome when a good person
hurts you
uh
i assume you're talking about mentally
or psychologically not physically
someone hurt you psychologically and
you're trying to get over it well you
know nobody can really hurt you
psychologically you hurt yourself you
hurt yourself because
you decided to get upset at some
disappointment
some expectation in you was was ruined
so you know you kind of just look at
that expectation you're like
you know
one way to to think about it might be to
rephrase that rather than saying
x hurt me or you know
somebody hurt me
the better way to think about it might
be
why did i hurt myself over how this
person behaved
it's it's essentially because you want
something out of them you have some
expectation out of them
and that expectation is the problem this
goes back to it's good to be detached
um if you want to be if you want to be
passionate or attached pick one thing
don't don't get attached to all kinds of
random people and and
your expectations out of them
i'm not saying it's easy i mean this is
the theory
um yeah someone said this is the ball
feeding his ego that's correct that's
why i'm here but you know why do we do
anything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you